if you're a hardcore fan of early Mario
games Super Mario Odyssey has a variety
of 2d platforming challenges to complete
and if you loved Super Mario Galaxy or
even sunshine this new adventures
mechanics and concepts represent those
games as most iconic elements in short
Nintendo's upcoming Odyssey has
something for everybody in many ways it
feels like a collection of Mario's best
offerings but it's also a fundamentally
new experience that welcomes you to
explore and experiment with the new
tools and adventures it provides if what
you discover here interests you be sure
to watch our latest Super Mario Odyssey
gameplay footage and don't forget to
subscribe so you don't miss any of our
coverage leading up to the game's
release on October 27th
during a recent Odyssey demo I got to
play two levels the luncheon Kingdom and
the seaside Kingdom both were visually
distinct exuding a vibrant and charming
aesthetic from the hard candy surfaces
that comprised the luncheon Kingdom to
the clear ocean waters of the seaside
Kingdom it was difficult to not be
enamoured by the splendor of it all
with Mario's diverse repertoire of jumps
and maneuvers navigating these areas was
a joy walljumps long jumps and rolls are
simple to pull off but like past 3d
Mario games they demand a high level of
skill and precision in order to utilize
to the fullest of their capability the
sense of control you have over Mario's
moves and the way they empower you when
correctly executed feels satisfying
moving and jumping feels just as
fine-tuned as in odyssey's predecessors
if not more so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
amidst the beautiful locales in the
minutiae of Mario's acrobatic jumps
there are a variety of activities to get
wrapped up in possessing enemies with
Mario's cat paves the way for a
multitude of different adventures one
moment I'm darting across pink lava is a
giant fire collecting a string of music
notes the next I'm smashing of cheese
rocks as a frying pan wielding hammer
bro to reveal moon shards this variety
is commonplace I'd often run towards an
area expecting to do one thing but end
up doing something completely different
Odysseys unexpected adventures keep me
guessing even in platforming sections
that feel familiar or reminiscent of
past games like breath of the wild
there's a deep emphasis in Odyssey on
charting your own unique experiences
while you're not given the same level of
freedom as in Zelda the sense of awe and
wonder you feel as you explore remains
the same the open areas you traverse and
the colorful characters you meet drive
this feeling forward the residents
include a pompous octo guy sitting atop
an ornate glass tower the mustachioed
snail the seashell necklace and a living
fork wearing a chef's hat cooking stew
and every new activity or personality
there is always something to latch on to
and with the game's photo mode there are
an abundance of moments worth
documenting
[Music]
in the two stages I played odyssey's
fine-tuned mechanics in vibrant
aesthetic already make it an enjoyable
Mario experience but to find out whether
or not the full game can maintain that
sense of wonder I'll have to wait until
October 27th when it launches on switch
if you have any specific questions about
my time at the game feel free to reach
out on twitter @ mg Espen and for more
Super Mario Odyssey coverage don't
forget to subscribe thanks for watching
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]